the Trump administration imposed a fresh
round of tariffs on European goods on
Friday they affect seven half billion
dollars worth of products including wine
liquor and Parmesan cheese in Italy
cheese producers say their traditional
product and its sale to the US is now
under threat Seth Doane has the story
from where else Parma Italy south good
morning good morning could your
spaghetti dinner be getting more
expensive this is a warehouse were
thousands of wheels of parmesan the real
stuff parmigiano-reggiano are aged for
years before being shipped around the
world and now the cheese destined for
America is also headed for a price hike
the price of their parmigiano-reggiano
was already at a premium
after all they control each step here
tracking which cows ate in which fields
and were milked on which day from
eternal Jenna's like Colosseum
is a piece of Italy Nicola Bertinelli is
the fourth generation to run his family
business in this specific region where
parmigiano-reggiano is made Bertinelli
who heads a group of cheese makers says
the u.s. is their second most important
export market and they plan to double
business there in the next five years at
least
until these tariffs we are worried that
the price is going to achieve a level
that after that it's a broken price
people won't buy it it's too expensive
she's from almost every country in the
EU will be hit by the 25% duty when you
look at the list they say hey why these
products are inside the list and the
other products are not the US tariffs
read like a shopping list of European
specialty products from clams to coffee
- whiskey produced in Scotland there's
yogurt or olives from Spain sparking
protests there
German tools are on the list so our
sweaters made in the UK French wine and
France in general is a big target the
unlikely trigger for these tariffs was
the 15-year battle between Boeing and
French airplane maker Airbus so aircraft
parts will get a 10% duty the US
government argues European subsidies
have undercut American workers it hurts
products that have nothing to do with
the dispute of Airbus and Boeing gun
Attilio Zanetti is Italy's biggest
exporter of parmigiano-reggiano he
estimates the price in a store could go
up by about $2 50 per pound so in other
words in simple words the American
consumer they're gonna pay for this at
Bertinelli's they're ready for a fight
and armed with their own spin let's say
Trump says American first
parmigiano-reggiano says American
consumers first it's a good line cheese
makers here say there is no match when
it comes to their tastes or tradition
and while they are used to competing for
a place in your grocery cart they say
these new US tariffs place unfair
pressure on both producers and consumers
for CBS this morning Saturday Seth Doane
Parma Italy hmm it's cool to see them
they're right in that it's hard to think
that the cheese we love so much is gonna
cost so much more when it's already
Michelle's going Italy she's going to
bring us back a whole bunch right wait
for that great